I think there is one part of the puzzle that many people are missing, including me until recently.
Volatility.
Everything is always moving, but it doesn't always move the same amount each day,
and we can actually see this in real time.
Let me show you why I think your trading isn't currently working the way it should.
We are currently looking at NASDAQ on a 30 second chart from 11am to 4pm.
Up until 1.30 where I have it hidden, we were getting around 5 points of movement on each 30 second candle.
這就是100$上的民主和10$上的螞蟻
無論外出,我們最多的一分的我們看到8分的動物
而最低的2分
所以 98%或是我們可以有30秒的動物
可以從2-8分的動物
這是正常的為 NASDAQ現在,當我做這個動物
你可以用這個動物來測試
要多久你會在一邊
一邊1-1 risk-reward 10-point trade
估计会几秒钟
几秒钟
有趣的事情
这次是一集中的一集
有什么事件
在真正中一集中的一集中15分钟这次是一集的大小,但这不是像其他大小的大小的大小,这些大小的大小小的大小小,
所以我做了什么,我去查询了什么,
这很有趣,很不错,
现在看起来的大小小,从这大小的大小小,
你能看到这些大小的大小的大小,
它是從2-8點到3.5-12點到3.5點到12點
很多人超過14點
所以這意義我們
我告訴你,這有點太多了
我發現我看到那一種平衡的平衡是最多的
那是我停止
當然,你可能會有同樣的零件
但它是真的,零件零件零件零件
同樣的東西是雙方,但現在是雙方的跌倒了
雙方是雙方的失敗,但也就是雙方的跌倒
雙方的雙方,也許多了,雙方的感受
但我喜歡看LATR看看我甚至至少待會再次讓我休息一下
這也是同樣的原因我很久就等了一會來凍結
特朗普通,你可能會賣或漏千萬萬元的錢
如果你不小心,都會有個操作的但還是,你s,但仍然是甚至是,他們的 micros大量增加了很多在價值上的負責當成價值,然後ATR
展示我們
正確實在現場的
我個人喜歡
dot clusters,
但一些人喜歡
這些
但是,
都最適合了
同樣的資料
現在,你當然不會
在這裏
同時,你不會
在平日的
看下,
你可以看到
這些盒子
1-4.25 points
Clearly, your stop losses and take profits would probably be smaller
since the chances of capturing a large move are unlikely
I knew that, yet somehow I wasn't being dynamic with my trading style
when volatility was different during the day
Moves are way different right now than what they used to be
and I'm not sure all of the traders out there are actually adapting to it
I certainly wasn't
I keep hearing people saying that trading is really hard right now
and part of me wonders if they have changed with the times
both your stop loss and take profit levels need to match with what's currently going on in the market
the charts always stretch out or become compact to automatically fit on the screen
so we don't always visually see when things are moving up and down more
we don't always notice that the horizontal price bars are moving in much higher or lower incrementsvisua看起來所以,ATR也提醒了我們事情是改變價格的價格
但它的上升,降降,降降,
和下降降,和下降
所以,我們的價格
需要合作這些改變
ATR也表示我們
看來這個
這個30秒數數數數
是從5到14秒數數
看著這些光額
這張圖像是一樣的
但這些圖像是只有2.5-7分別
請看你的計劃也要改變
當價值是半個多的
或是三個多的
你其實是否調整這個
而是否調整這個
而是否調整
或是否調整
和你的狀況
和狀況
這給我一場
一場最重要的影響
我的經驗
如果一般的5點是5點值得到15點值得到
不可能我會被控制了,不可能我會被控制了,
不可能我會被控制了,不可能我會被控制了
我們必須改變到改變的情況下,在現場中,每天的情況下
和ATR會告訴你,你需要做什麼
謝謝,粉絲,好運氣,大家